noch deutlicher verfehlen das cdu spd
und grüne
und auch wenn die fdp noch mit dabei
wäre reichte es nur für 38 sitze
das ungewöhnliche bündnis aus linken spd
grünen und fdp käme genau auf die 45
sitze derzeit die man braucht und auch
wenn die cdu das ausgeschlossen hat
zeigen was hier mal linke und cdu käme
auf 49 sitze
das wäre dann deutlich drüber die
wahlbeteiligung ist deutlich gestiegen
auf 66 prozent
tja was macht man jetzt daraus das ist
die große frage die auch den ganzen
abend schon diskutiert folgen ist bodo
ramelow der ministerpräsident der linken
er will das bleiben und hatte auch ganz
klar den anspruch erhoben eine regierung
bilden zu wollen
wir hören war ein was er hier bei uns im
zdf wahlstudio gesagt hat also das ist
doch nun eindeutig einerseits bei den
beliebtheitswerten andererseits dass wir
einen so kräftigen auftrag bekommen
haben dass meine partei auch noch mal
zugelegt hat ist doch ein deutlicher
ausdruck dafür dass die wählerinnen und
wähler erwarten dass von mir die
regierungsbildung vorangetrieben wird
und deswegen bin ich ein bisschen
verwundert dass die union die eine große
wahlniederlage gerade verkraften muss
dass diese union sich jetzt hinstellt
und den wählern gegenüber sagt das sei
keine demokratische mitte also die mitte
dieses landes ist das land als solches
und nicht eine einzelne partei sagt bodo
ramelow während seine partei die linke
schafft feiert hier in erfurt da hören
wer ist noch mächtig was los christian
christina von ungern sternberg ist dabei
ja die stimmung ist gut trotz der
schwierigen regierungsverhältnisse
bettina das kann man nicht anders sagen
hier ergeht bei den linken der punk ab
auch wenn sich das ein bisschen albern
anhört muss man sagen hier wird gefeiert
sie warten alle noch auf bodo ramelow
der bahn nämlich noch gar nicht hier um
sich feiern zu lassen
für sein hund der terrier atilla der ist
schon da und zwei fragen treibt
natürlich die leute hier bei der
linkspartei heute abend um wie sehr kann
man dieses ergebnis feiern und was macht
man jetzt damit und jetzt über gehe ich
einfach mir mal die kleine müde
anwesende und fragt die mama wie stolz
sind sie denn auch das ergebnis heute
abend sehr stolz wir haben viel dafür
getan der der viele unserer
landtagswahlkampf der war enorm
es war mein erster ich bin nämlich sehr
früh weiter verteilt und nina als quasi
die jüngste das als jüngstes mitglied
leitwährung strichen genau und sehr
stolz als klar dankeschön und was machen
sie jetzt mit dem ergebnis ist eine
koalition mit der cdu für sie
vorstellbar und noch mike mohring nicht
er hat ja eben in seinen interviews
immer noch gesorgt und seine niederlage
noch gar nicht eingestanden
ich denke wenn eine regierungsbildung
möglich wäre dann wahrscheinlich her mit
der fdp
alles klar soweit sind wir noch nicht
kurze fragen noch an nina wie es die
party
ich nehme das man als ja alles klar
vielen dank und damit zurück zu euch ins
studio bettina an christina ist freuen
sich offenkundig doch nicht alle so also
man muss noch einmal deutlich machen das
ist für die linke ein wirklich
historischer sieg sie führt klar hier
die rangliste an auf rang zwei bei
dieser wahl in thüringen ist die afg
gelandet mit zuletzt mit zuletzt jetzt
will ich genau sein 23,9 in unserer
hochrechnung und wir haben wir vorhin
auf der erfurter wahlparty sprechen
können mein kollege martin cordes im
gespräch mit dem parteivorsitzenden
download von hier steht alexander
gauland parteivorsitzender der fdp
gauland dieses ergebnis war dass ein
ergebnis für die afg wegen oder trotz
das ist ein ergebnis für die afg mit
hacke wieder wegen noch trotz werke er
ist der spitzenkandidat gewesen hat
einen guten wahlkampf gemacht also ist
es ein ergebnis für uns alle mit höcker
aber viele der partei wollen den
einfluss von herrn rücken nicht weiter
steigen sehen
bricht jetzt ein machtkampf zitterpartie
ich sehe niemand in der partei der sich
über den einfluss von heute gedanken
macht ein siegreicher landesverband hat
natürlich einfluss das geht war für
brandenburg das gilt für sachsen das
gilt auch für thüringen welche
auswirkungen das hat das keine ging
heute nicht sagen
vielen dank herr gauland zurück ins
studium
auf rang 3 dann die cdu und für den
spitzenkandidaten mike mohring war damit
jetzt mit seinem sehr schwachen ergebnis
auch zunächst mal die hoffnung zerstoben
hier eine regierungsmehrheit anbieten zu
können wir haben eine situation matthias
fornoff in dem eben die avisierten
bündnisse nicht tragen
und jetzt gucken wir uns das noch mal an
was denn eigentlich die thüringer von
einer minderheitsregierung erteilen
würden es wird so schwierig wie wir es
vorhergesehen haben so kommt es jetzt
auch und wir haben die situation in
thüringen dass die regierung die im amt
ist im amt bleibt bis ein neuer
ministerpräsident oder
ministerpräsidentin gewählt wird wir
haben gefragt was halten denn die
thüringer von einer minderheitsregierung
29 prozent finden das gut aber gute zwei
drittel sagen das wäre schlecht
das ist ein ziemlich klares ergebnis
aber möglicherweise wird es erstmal so
kommen müssen denn es muss sich jemand
bewegen um ein mehrheitsfähiges bündnis
hierzu stellen wir haben gesehen vorhin
linke und cdu das könnte zusammengehen
aber der cdu generalsekretär
mit dem wir in unserer wahlsendung
gesprochen haben hat sich auch nach
links noch einmal sehr deutlich
abgegrenzt das hörte sich so an meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren wir
sehen auch bei dieser wahl dass es in
den letzten tagen bis zu einer wahl ein
trend hin zum amtierenden
ministerpräsidenten gibt der aber auch
in diesem neuen landtag nunmehr keine
parlamentarische mehrheit mehr hat
es gibt aber auch keine mehrheit für
eine regierung aus der mitte heraus
ich sage es ihnen heute abend ganz klar
unser wort gilt nach den wahlen genau so
wie wir es vor den wahlen gesagt hat
haben es wird keine koalition der cdu
mit der linkspartei oder der afg geben
so das wollten wir ihnen noch einmal
zeigen also erschließt das noch einmal
klar aus in beide richtungen und wir
finden dass die wähler wieder
verhältnisse könnte man so natürlich
auch bekommen und wir haben mal gefragt
die cdu hat eine koalition mit link
und mit afd ausgeschlossen finden sie
das eigentlich richtig wir fangen mal
hier an für die linke
da sagen fast 60 prozent das ist nicht
richtig nur ein drittel stimmt dazu ein
ganz anderes bild das man die koalition
mit der afg ausschließt dass finden 61
prozent richtig und nur ein gutes
drittel widerspricht da dankeschön
matthias dann ziehen wir mal einen
ersten strich drunter wo stehen wir
jetzt professor karl rudolf korte ist
bei uns und er hat auch ein eigenes
micro deshalb kann ich dies wieder
weglegen
noch hat sich keiner wirklich bewegen
sondern die position von vor der wahl
wurden jetzt hier nochmal fixiert auch
bei uns vorhin in der 19 uhr
runde aber glauben sie dass das noch mal
wirklich jetzt zur sprache kommen wird
ein bündnis linke cdu kann da am ende
doch was gehen ja mit verändert personen
das wurde angedeutet dann in der sendung
gab es hinweise dass ein themen angebot
gemacht wird von den linken was die cdu
an die vorgeschlagen hatte also direkte
demokratie elemente und andererseits
habe ich bei der fdp hier auch raus
gehört dass da gesprächsbereit über
themen ganz klar erkennbar ist also
keine abgrenzung wer also schöpferisch
experimente unterwegs ist kann weimarer
verhältnisse verhindern
dennoch ist die frage kann daraus mehr
werden als ein übergang szenario also
wie lange hält zum beispiel eine
geschäftsführende regierung die ja
möglich ist hier in thüringen heißt das
nicht im grunde dann innerhalb eines
jahres neu war
sie ist unbefristet im amt man könnte
mit mut eine ministerpräsidenten wahl
durchführen und auf eine einfache
mehrheit am ende setzen also auf
minderheiten dann gewählt mit
gesetzgeberische möglichkeit dass der
landtag in düsseldorf hat zwei jahre
überlebt mit so einer form mit
unterschiedlichen mehrheiten und über
eine tolerierungsmodell gab es zwei
legislaturperioden sogar in magdeburg
über das magdeburger modell also es gibt
möglichkeiten das regierung sich länger
halten sowohl geschäftsführend als auch
als minderheiten toleriert also damit
liegt eigentlich tatsächlich der ball
bei bodo ramelow denn er kann jetzt
erstmal bleiben im grunde mit seiner
regierung genau hat den
gestaltungsauftrag auf jeden fall den er
heute abend ja auch betont hat
wahrzunehmen und er muss jetzt
präsentiert
das kann er ja punktuelle mehrheiten
versuchen für einzelne themen zu finden
und damit werben damit wandelt sich
plötzlich die machtpolitik komplett aus
der staatskanzlei in das parlament dass
politik muss mit im parlament die
souveränität der abgeordneten wird viel
größer
es wird sehr turbulent im hinblick auf
ideenvielfalt das wird viele abgeordnete
freuen
es wird turbulent hat denn mike mohring
der spitzenkandidat der cdu
irgendetwas vor augen möglicherweise
wenn er sagt genauso wie andere aus der
cdu wir müssen jetzt schnell stabile
verhältnisse unter cdu-führung schaffen
was ist da denn überhaupt denkbar also
dass es auch möglich mit einzelnen
themen vielleicht gemeinsam etwas zu
finden das man unterstützen könnte das
ist nicht grundsätzlich auszuschließen
aber auch seine rolle heraus sehr schwer
weil das doch im kern darauf gezielt die
kraft träume der demokratie die sich
ganz sichtbar heute verengt haben durch
das ergebnis auch durch die
zweitplatzierung der afc offen zu halten
und da ist eigentlich jeder erst mal
aufgerufen aber die cdu muss erstmal
diese dramatische wal niederlage
verkraften und daraus wieder eine
positive energie zu ziehen das wird
schwer sein ist die frage auch ob sie
das mit diesem kandidaten dann könnten
zu der dramatischen wahlniederlage
gehört auch der befund dass die afg
jedenfalls nach der hochrechnung sogar
auf rang zwei vor der cdu liegt wie
bewerten sie das fd ergebnis ja die
krafträume der demokratie werden enger
auch dadurch dass eine partei die ja
doch vom verfassungsschutz nicht
kontrolliert wird aber doch überwacht
wird als prüfer hier offenbar auf so
große resonanz stößt mit einer klar
ideologischen festlegung das
unterscheidet sie von manch anderem
landesverband und wenn sich hier in
diesem land durch setzt man kann nicht
alles sagen ohne dass die sozialen
kosten der stigmatisierung und es
ausgrenzen tuch sind dann ist dies ein
klima was durchaus zu weimar passt
professor kurt der herzlichen dank für
die interessante analyse
ja und das ist viel stoff jetzt für die
berliner runde dazu gebe ich jetzt
direkt ab live ins zdf hauptstadtstudio
in berlin
in unser theo koll wir melden uns danach
zurück die nächsten 30 minuten gehören
berlin
vielen dank bettina und damit herzlich
willkommen zur berliner runde in der wir
uns das wahlergebnis mit blick auf die
bundespolitik betrachten wollen zu gast
sind die generalsekretäre
beziehungsweise bundes oder
parlamentarischen geschäftsführer der im
bundestag in fraktionsstärke vertretenen
parteien ich begrüße
als erste die einzige dame in der runde
linda teuteberg generalsekretärin der
fdp herzlich willkommen sowie die sie
umgebenden herrn paul signac
generalsekretär der cdu
markus blume generalsekretär der csu und
michael kellner bundesgeschäftsführer
von bündnis 90 die grünen
und wenn wir in der runde weitergehen
auf der anderen seite des tisches
begrüße ich bernd baumann
parlamentarischer geschäftsführer der
afd
jörg schindler bundesgeschäftsführer die
linke und lars klingbeil generalsekretär
der spd in allen einen guten abend herr
schindler mit dem besten ergebnis das
sie bisher bei einer wahl überhaupt
erzielt haben mit abstand stärkste kraft
in thüringen welche lehre zieht ihre
partei im bund aus diesem ergebnis von
bodo ramelow mit dem hintergrund er
genießt als konservativer linker dort
hohes ansehen auch bei cdu-wählern
akzeptabel
im bund dagegen ist die linke viel
linker und viel weniger erfolgreich sie
hatten bei der europawahl mit 5,5
prozent das schlechteste ergebnis aller
zeiten also ist thüringen thüringen oder
lässt sich dann möglicherweise etwas
lernen dass ich mich natürlich heute
hier froh darüber dass bruno latour
amilo und die thüringer linke ein
grandioses wahlergebnis erreicht hat
bodo ramelow als ministerpräsident
eindrucksvoll im amt bestätigt worden
und auch auf der bundes partei ebene
kann ich mich darüber nur freuen weil
genau die politik die bodo ramelow in
thüringen macht ist die politik die wir
auch auf bundesebene vertreten nämlich
auf der einen seite radikalem herangehen
und auf der anderen seite dann
pragmatisch wenn es darum geht das
umzusetzen ist völlig auseinander also
hier haben sie ein sehr linkes image bei
den bei den wählern mit 5,5 prozent das
schlechteste ergebnis aller zeiten und
in thüringen ist es jemand der auch bei
cdu-wählern akzeptabel ist nun die
themen die bodo ramelow anspricht und
auch die wir als linke ansprechen sind
nach themen die weit darüber hinausgehen
also wenn hier zum beispiel in thüringen
das azubi ticket eingeführt worden ist
wenn wir hier ein vergabe- mindestlohn
von 11 eur 42 eingeführt hat sind das
genau die themen die auch auf
bundesebene notwendig wären einzuführen
das ist ein punkt die unterscheidung es
dann keine an keiner stelle ich sehe da
ihren unterschied nicht erziehen wir
schauen wir auf die cdu es reicht ja für
keine der koalition der mitte
sie hätten in thüringen einen
ministerpräsidenten der ein
konservativer linker ist von dem viele
ihrer wähler sagen der ist akzeptabel
und dennoch verweigern sie sich an einer
solchen koalition
das müssen sie uns erklären wir
verweigern uns nicht sondern wir stehen
zu unserem wort wir halten das ein was
wir vor der wahl versprochen haben und
der bereits eine mögliche koalition es
wäre jetzt eine mögliche rechnerische
koalition
aber ich sage ihnen ganz deutlich es
geht ja auch um die frage von
glaubwürdigkeit und die frage zu welchen
wert man steht mit jemandem der bis
heute nicht bereit ist anzuerkennen dass
die ddr ein unrechtsstaat war
wo soll dann die grundlage für eine
zusammenarbeit mit der cdu seien
wir haben es auf dem bundesparteitag
besprochen und beschlossen mike mohring
hatte selbst vor der wahl immer
wiederholt wir werden nicht mit der
linkspartei und nicht mit der albertina
quali-runde der händler vor ort ja aber
sehen sie werden diskutieren doch häufig
genug über beliebigkeit in der politik
und wenn jetzt eine umfrage mal kommt
wenn jetzt diskutiert wird er es gebe
eine rechnerische mehrheit heißt das
doch nicht dass man alle seine
grundsätze als christdemokrat über bord
wirft und sagt na ja gut jetzt geht es
rechnerisch also werte egal inhalte egal
hauptsache regieren ist nicht mein stil
von politik auch nicht
der von mike mohring und der cdu herr
blume als partner in der union der
unionskandidat in thüringen mike mohring
hat wörtlich gesagt eine neue regierung
hat die aufgabe das land
zusammenzuhalten wir müssen brücken
bauen aber eine logische folge von
brücken bauen wäre doch auch eine
koalition telling ziemlich jetzt hier
keine assistenz in der frage aber ich
kann nur sagen ja die in allem was er
gerade formuliert hat recht und
vielleicht sollte man es auch noch mal
genauer anschauen was in thüringen
passiert ist das ergebnis für die union
bitte ohne frage vor allem weil mike
mohring einen extrem engagierten
wahlkampf geführt hat aber es ist vor
allem dramatisch auch für unsere
demokratie war zum ersten mal im
nachkriegsdeutschland die kräfte der
ränder die kräfte der extreme eine
parlamentarische mehrheit haben und auch
über das muss man an diesem heutigen
abend reden übrigens der sündenfall der
es vor fünf jahren passiert als spd und
grüne nicht eine koalition der mitte
gebildet haben sondern damals eine
koalition mit den linken ermöglicht
haben und die das ergebnis ist das was
ich heute hier präsentiert
deswegen sage ich ganz klar augen auf
bei der koalitions war für uns als union
ist hier an der stelle ganz klar keine
bündnisse mit den radikalen aber wenn
die spreizung genauso ist in der
wählerschaft wie sie gerade beschrieben
haben müssen sie dann nicht über neue
bündnisse nachdenken
ich glaube wir reden zu viel über
bündnisse und zu wenig was eigentlich
die parteien selbst ausmacht und wenn
ich jetzt mal den blick allgemein auf
uns als union richten darf dann geht es
um unsere kernkompetenzen geht es um die
fragen für die wir stehen als csu als
cdu und natürlich muss man mit einem
solchen wahlergebnis dann auch umgehen
das ist aber dann angelegenheit
natürlich in thüringen mir ist
eigentlich wichtiger dass wir solche
zustände in deutschland in zukunft nicht
mehr habe nun regiert das ist etwas was
dieses land nicht kennt und wir sollten
alles tun nun zwar gerade mit der kraft
aus der mitte heraus sicher zu stellen
sich das nicht mehr wiederholt haben wir
die afg hat massiv dazu gewonnen mit
blick auf den bund was heißt das
ergebnis für die künftige bedeutung von
birke in machtgefüge ihrer partei
wie gestärkt ist er nach dieser wahl der
mann ist einer von 16 landesvorsitzenden
die wir haben in der in der republik das
wahlergebnis zeigt so nicht einmal den
wähler will das zieht nicht auf eine
einzelne person
die wähler haben uns in sachsen das
ergebnis verdreifachte sie haben es uns
in brandenburg verdoppelt sie haben der
afg heute abend das ergebnis mehr als
verdoppelt das ist doch ein klares
signal dass der wähler will
es gibt eine bürgerliche mehrheit
jenseits für links grün aber die
entsprechende kräfte sondern grund auch
wahrnehmen merkel repräsentiert ja ein
teil ihrer parteien nämlich den flügel
das heißt denn das für die künftige
machtposition des flügel in der partei
helke ist landesvorsitzender
fraktionsvorsitzender hier in thüringen
er hat den wahlkampf geführt er macht
hier seit vier jahren opposition und die
wähler haben das mit dem besten ergebnis
das jemals eine partei in so kurzer zeit
erzielen könnte sozusagen bewertet und
das heißt ja nur dass er im ansehen der
wähler schafft vorne liegt das ist
anzuerkennen dass wird seine partei
natürlich auch eine rolle spielt das
heißt er wird wichtiger jeder der gute
parteipolitik macht und gute wahlen
vorlegt wird wichtiger als in jeder
partei so erklären wir die spd verliert
weiter deutlich unter zehn prozent
obwohl sie in thüringen
schlüsselressorts innehatten ist die
lehre daraus wie im bund ja auch das
junior partner zu sein ein aderlass für
die spd ist das ist ein bitteres
ergebnis für uns enttäuschend wir hatten
auf mehr gehofft wir haben gesehen wie
die regierungsbilanz ist dies positiv in
thüringen wir haben gesehen dass
wolfgang tiefensee auch als person sehr
positive werte hat und trotzdem konnte
die spd nicht davon profitieren weil wir
eine ähnliche situation haben das will
ich sagen wie in sachsen und brandenburg
wo starke ministerpräsidenten gekämpft
haben am ende und sagen das land vor der
entscheidung stand ob die rechtsextremen
die stärkste kraft im land werden oder
ob die amtierenden ministerpräsidenten
im amt bleiben und davon haben dann die
parteien wie die spd heute genauso nicht
die empfindlichen kollegen sagen bodo
ramelow hat davon profitiert dass es
diese zuspitzung mit der fdp gab und
das ist die situation wie wir sie in
thüringen heute erlebt haben das nochmal
die risiken sind aderlass wenn sie
juniorpartner sind das kann man daraus
ablesen gerade das ist schwierig ist
wenn man juniorpartner ist aber trotzdem
drückt man sich nicht vor verantwortung
da gibt es ja andere parteien am tisch
die das ja anscheinend tun
seit gestern abend wissen wir jetzt
welche teams bei ihnen die stichwahl
gehen
was heißt das schwache thüringer
ergebnis für die groko befindlichkeit in
ihrer partei das ist das wahlergebnis
aus thüringen hören was dort sozusagen
ist eine landespolitische entscheidung
ich sehe nicht dass es für die berliner
politik große rückschlüsse gibt was ich
hier sagen will ist dass ich mir
natürlich gewünscht hätte dass wir beim
thema grundrente eine einigung
hinbekommen dass wir ein wichtiges
signal auch für die menschen gerade in
den ostdeutschen bundesländern gewesen
dass man lebensleistung anerkennt da
sind wir in konstruktiven gesprächen ich
hoffe wir kommen da schnell voran so was
vor der wahl in thüringen wäre gut
gewesen aber die auswirkungen auf die
bundespolitik auf die frage ob der
koalition die sie angesprochen haben
die sehe ich erst mal nicht weil es vor
allem eine landes zu politische
zuspitzung war jedoch haben sie mir
selber gesagt ein juniorpartner zu sein
kostet sie etwas und das wäre ja
übertragen auf die groko situation in
berlin
genau das signal in diese stichwort
hinein ja aber ich ziehe da keine
schlüsse daraus jetzt gerade für die
bundespolitik wir haben jetzt eine
schwierige situation in thüringen
wir müssen jetzt entscheiden wie eine
regierung aussehen kann ich nehme wahr
dass jetzt mehr gesagt man duckt sich da
weg dass man nicht in verantwortung
gehen will und das halte ich ja weil das
halte ich für ein stand zu stand das
will ich sagen und ich verstehe auch das
möchte ich noch mal deutlich voneinander
haben wir heute dass man auf einmal
herrn röcke wie man als faschisten
bezeichnen kann in diesem land und
moderato dass man diese beiden
gleichsetzen an einem solchen wahlabend
wo die brandstifter mit 24 prozent knapp
in den landtag in thüringen einziehen
das halte ich für ein völlig falsches
signal die eine gleichsetzung sondern
ist ein solches ausmaß von vela
beschimpfung jeder vierte wähler hat die
afg hüppe gewählt dann kommen sie in
ihrem hohen ross herunter die wähler
laufen ihnen doch weg die afg ist
dreimal so stark wie sie wann merken sie
der kellner ruggeller über 20 prozent
bei der europawahl in umfragen
regelmäßig ja höhenflüge im osten aber
jetzt zum dritten mal als ikarus geerdet
warum sind die grünen so schwach im
osten
sie haben in thüringen unser ein
ergebnis was mich persönlich sehr
enttäuscht hätte mir viel mehr erhofft
und es nicht gelungen aus zugreifen
nicht gelungen ländlichen raum zuzulegen
und anders als in brandenburg und
sachsen war sein vieh polarisierte
wahlkampf uns hat der wind sehr ins
gesicht geweht und wir haben es nicht
geschafft den erfolg zu erkämpfen die
man auch in brandenburg hatte nur
lindern
im vergangenen jahr hatten habe ich
möchte auch mal ne frage hat was heißt
es eigentlich eine regierungsbildung in
thüringen bodo ramelow und dazu
glückwunsch hat die wahl gewonnen es ist
die linkspartei in thüringen man kann
sie nicht vergleichen weder mit der
af.de noch es ist eine das ist der
sozialdemokratische partei in thüringen
eine eine bessere sozusagen
erfolgreichere und ehrlich gesagt wenn
ich mir anschaue ich verstehe die
argumente das ist schwer fällt und ich
verstehe die argumente bei fdp ich
verstehe die argumente bei union
aber wir haben auch als grüne gesagt im
parteiensystem was in deutschland so im
wandel ist denn müssen demokratische
parteien miteinander reden können mit
allen außer der afg und ich habe nach
der bundestagswahl haben wir auch mit
mit cdu csu fdp geredet bis christian
lindner davon gekoppelt ist und ich
finde die zeiten die zeiten in denen wir
leben ist es richtig dass man
miteinander redet und schaut kriegt man
eine stabile regierung in thüringen
die anderen überzeugen und das ja auch
von ist ja eine vierer koalition
wünschen also mit der linken spd grüne
und fdp bisher in dieser form noch nie
gegeben hat wenn das eine mehrheit wäre
sie wären dabei
wir sind dabei das zu sagen wir müssen
mit diesen wahl ergibt es darum gehen
wir müssen versuchen für thüringen für
thüringen situationen und ich finde das
ändert hat auch noch mal die die
ausgangslage wohl wo eine an afg mit
einem faschisten an der spitze 24
prozent bekommt das verändert auch die
situation
und dann müssen wir reden sowie rind
auch in sachsen-anhalt kenia gemacht hat
glaube ich kein kein koalitionsmodell
auf das was wir uns gefreut haben wir
gesagt haben das wollen wir dafür haben
wir wahlkampf gemacht und wir waren
bereit verantwortung für das land
übernehmen
für sachsen anhalt und jetzt ist es halt
die frage wie kann man in thüringen eine
stabile regierung bilden das finde ich
schon sehr aktive frage genau dieselbe
frage
sie wenn eine vierer koalition möglich
ist unter führung der linken spd grüne
und fdp wären sie dabei wir haben wir
sind angetreten auch um diese regierung
ramelow zu beenden aber für uns ist
erstmal die frage heute in aller demut
das endergebnis abzuwarten wir brauchen
heute starke nerven
die bei liberalen immer unverzichtbar
sind und alle fragen nach bündnissen
stellen sich erst danach aber wir sind
haben ganz klare haltungen das für
rot-rot-grün beenden wollen und werden
dann wenn wir das endergebnis kennen
verantwortlich damit umgehen
das hieße jetzt für die vierer koalition
das werden wir sicherlich mit unserem
landesverband der besprechen wir haben
streben das auf keinen fall an und
werden jetzt das endergebnis abwarten
müssen
okay das heißt sie schließen sie aber
nicht aus die fdp ist jetzt
möglicherweise im landtag vertreten bei
den beiden letzten landtagswahlen waren
sie es nicht
was ist los mit der fdp sie sind in der
opposition die regierung bietet nicht
das beste bild und sie scheinen aber
nicht wirklich davon zu profitieren
zunächst mal abgesehen davon dass wir
jetzt abwarten ob es dann am ende reicht
ist zu sehen dass wir unser ergebnis
verdoppelt haben relativ absolut sogar
bei einer sehr hohen wahlbeteiligung die
uns als demokraten immer freut mehr als
verdoppelt haben das ist ein erfolg und
wir hoffen jetzt dass es reicht denn
dass es eine verhaltene freude übrigens
aus verantwortung denn insgesamt hätten
wir uns gewünscht dass die politische
mitte stärker wird bei diesen wahlen
aber wir wollen genau die verantwortung
wahrnehmen dass wir aus der mit sitz und
stimme im landtag noch mehr tun können
für die politische mitte deshalb würden
wir uns freuen wenn es reicht und haben
ein sehr gutes ergebnis bisherige zu
verzeichnen und werden jetzt in aller
demut abwarten ob es dafür reicht und
uns dann verantwortlich ein kurzer blick
auf die situation im bund die groko wenn
man es salopp formulieren will nervt
sich ja seit anbeginn dauerstreit jetzt
auch um die grundrente ganz aktuell
streiten sich sogar
verteidigungsministerin und
außenminister in der großen koalition
nähert sich das verfallsdatum dieser
koalition
ich glaube dass viele einfach keine lust
mehr haben die ganze zeit diese debatten
zu führen was ist mit der groko gibt es
morgen die gruppe sondern die menschen
erwarten einfach dass wir mit den themen
vorband kommen zum beispiel zwei nicht
nur menschen sondern meine sohn bei der
grund handeln dagegen ja natürlich wenn
ich sehe was der außenminister dass der
außenminister mit seinem türkischen
amtskollegen sich so verhält wie er sich
jetzt verhalten hat dann fehlt mir jedes
verständnis dafür
das ist nicht die art wie wir
miteinander umgehen jetzt muss es darum
gehen dass wir weiter darüber sprechen
was ist wichtig für die menschen also
probleme lösen und nicht eine eigene
beschäftigung deswegen kommentiere ich
auch nicht das was bei der spd gerade
passiert das muss die spd schon selbst
tun als union sprechen wir darüber was
ist jetzt wichtig in dieser
legislaturperiode bis zum ende der
legislaturperiode noch zu erreichen also
verfallsdatum ist erst das ende
nein es ist das also unser ziel ist dass
diese dieser koalitionsvertrag
abgearbeitet wird dass wir die komplette
legislaturperiode regieren und das wir
aber ganz klar sagen wir halten uns an
den koalitionsvertrag und diskutieren
nicht alle zwei wochen über die groko
über interne dinge über fragen von
kanzlerkandidatur mike mohring hat ja
ein super wahlkampf gemacht weil er
selber auch mit viel leidenschaft und
das was sie sich gewünscht hat dass über
thüringen gesprochen wird und nicht über
andere dinge aber wir sind ja jetzt auch
hier um über die auswirkungen für den
boden zu reden wir haben bei der spd
jetzt gesehen gestern die beiden duo die
antreten
groko skeptisch dass eine olaf scholz er
für die groko müssen sie im grunde jetzt
sind sie in der zwangslage olaf scholz
ein gutes grund rentenmodell anzubieten
damit die groko überlebt damit er
gewählt hat also alles was wir machen
müssen auch bei der grundrente muss
erstens finanzierbar sein zweites
denjenigen helfen die es brauchen und
wir dürfen und da muss sich lars
klingbeil wieder sprechen nur weil ein
wahltag ein wahltermin ansteht ist das
kein grund etwas zu machen was falsch am
ende des tages ist sondern wir brauchen
eine grundrente die durchfinanziert ist
die sinnvoll ist und das ist doch viel
zu häufig in den letzten monaten und
jahren gewesen dass wir von wahltermin
zu wahltermin gucken damit wird man
nicht erfolgreich und deswegen ja wir
brauchen dort ein klares ergebnis aber
so wie sie im koalitionsvertrag fallen
wir klingen weil wenn das die
ausgangslage ist und wenn die gruppe und
ich so kommt die entschuldung die
grundrente nicht so kommt wie sie ist
jetzt wünschen ist das das ende der
gruppe also erstmal es ist ja nicht nur
lars klingbeil der für die grundrente
plädiert sondern auch mike mohring hat
ja richtig druck gemacht konnte sich der
leiter innerhalb der union ist immer
dann der schnelle lösung hin bekommt
aber ich bin guter dinge dass es jetzt
bald soweit ist und für die grundrente
auch hinbekommen und dann gilt das was
im koalitionsvertrag steht wir sind die
erste bundesregierung die gesagt hat wir
ziehen eine zwischenbilanz das sagt ja
nicht die spd sondern das sagen wir alle
diese regierung hat einen vertrag
abgeschlossen bis zum ende legislatur
aber wir werden in der mitte eine bilanz
ziehen und werden gucken was haben wir
geschafft und was haben wir noch vor
und ich sage da ganz klar die spd ist
dann überzeugt da wenn eine gute
grundrente schon erreicht ist bis zur
halbzeit bilanz und daran arbeiten wird
es glaube ich gerade gemeinsam wenn sie
nicht so kommt wie von ihnen gewünscht
eine halbzeitbilanz mit grundrente ist
besser für die spd als eine
halbzeitbilanz ohne grund wir eine
grundrente an sich ist ja nicht steht ja
nicht infrage in frage ist wie aber die
nächste mal gucken ist ein gutes modell
hinbekommen was für uns wichtig ist dass
wir union hatte mal vorgeschlagen so
knapp 150000 menschen da sagen wir das
muss deutlich mehr werden
es gibt deutlich mehr menschen die
wirklich verdient haben auch in würde
alt zu werden und im alter etwas oben
drauf zu kriegen und wir sagen auch da
darf kein riesiges bürokratiemonster
aufgebaut werden und in dem sinne
verhandeln wir und nochmal ich bin
optimistisch dass wir das hinbekommen
aber für die halbzeitbilanz ist das
schon jugendlichen selbst mit grundrente
fresken die eine gewinnerin ihrer stich
war gestern sagt raus aus der gruppe
aber das entscheidet ja nicht eine
person in der spd sondern das wird ein
bundesparteitag sich genau anschauen der
wird diese halbzeitbilanz auch bewerten
und dann gucken wir mal wie's weitergeht
schauen wir auf die linke im bund sahra
wagenknecht tritt bei frau kipping ist
der verbleib noch offen
sagen sie uns mal wie die linke sich
künftig positionieren wird auch mit dem
hintergrund bodo ramelow konservativen
erfolg im land also ich will zunächst
mal auf das wort aufgreifen von vom
haltbarkeitsdatum und ich würde sagen
die haltbarkeit der großen koalition
zeigt sich dass jetzt wieder in
thüringen ist doch schon seit langem
überschritten das produkt ist
ungenießbar
die personen können sich hier nicht mehr
auf die grundrente einigen
übrigen die grundrente da geht es ja
darum dass millionen von menschen nicht
zum sozialamt müssen also es geht hier
nicht etwa um irgend ein luxusprodukt
oder das geht ja eigentlich um eine
existenz um existenz menschenwürdige
existenz und wenn man sich darauf nicht
einigen kann als große koalition dann
weiß ich nicht was das sein soll
wir stehen dafür dass die zukunftsfragen
endlich angegangen werden das sind
investitionsstau das ist auch und war in
thüringen jetzt hier ein thema die
einführung von kostenfreie bildung etwa
beim kindergarten
das sind dinge die wir weiterführen
wollen ich finde das hat thüringen
gezeigt beim blick auf das was gestern
in der spd präsentiert wurde die beiden
teams die jetzt die den parteivorsitz
ringen hoffen sie darauf dass es ein
team wird das am ende dann für
rot-rot-grün bereit ist
selbstverständlich ich habe ja auch im
eigenen team schon zu sichern guten
wahlergebnis gratuliert aber das
entscheidend gott sei dank die spd
selbstverständlich die linke das
selbstverständlich aber gerade die
anlage ist ja auch noch heute werk in
berlin eine regierung die sich seit
anbeginn soft die an sich selbst leidet
sie als oppositionspartei müssten doch
im grunde davon massiv profitieren warum
passiert das nicht
zunächst mal sind wir von den parteien
der mitte der bundesrepublik der
etablierten parteien die einzige die im
bund stabiles und wir heute in thüringen
zugelegt hat insofern sind wir stabil
und konsolidieren und gleichzeitig in
ostdeutschland dass die lage schwierig
es ist klar aber wir benutzen eben auch
nicht für rhetorik der spaltung und
profitieren nicht von polarisierung
sondern machen weiter vernünftige
vorschläge der politischen mitte umso
mehr freut es uns wenn es sich
bestätigen sollte dass wir es damit
schaffen
in thüringen auch wieder parlamentarisch
zu werden ich glaube das muss man doch
heute noch mal feststellen wenn es
gelingen sollte wäre es das was uns zum
letzten mal vor zehn jahren gelangen aus
einer außerparlamentarischen opposition
wieder den einzug in ein parlament in
ostdeutschland zu schaffen
insofern wäre das nicht wenig und das
ist ein gutes ecke aber dennoch noch mal
die frage sie haben sie erleben ja
gerade auch den zustand der großen
koalition warum profitiert die fdp nicht
stärker davon
nun wir sind stabiler als wir jemals
waren in
in der politik und wir arbeiten steigern
oder ja aber auf einem niveau das früher
sehr ungewöhnlich war für die fdp auf
einem sehr guten niveau und sie sehen
das auch in ostdeutschland das übrigens
kontinuierlich bessere ergebnisse werden
auch wenn der anlauf sehr schwer ist in
ländern in denen man vorher nicht im
landtag ist und fünf jahre nicht medial
und auch mit ehrenamtlichen
mandatsträger vorkommt aber wir haben
einen guten wahlkampf gemacht der sich
offenbar auch auszahlt und wir machen
weiter im bundestag unsere vorschläge
und bekommen dafür sehr viel
unterstützung in der bevölkerung habe
ihr parteichef markus söder sagt zitat
die groko ist kein zukunftsmodell
sie vermittelt personell und strukturell
zu wenig perspektive wir haben eben
gehört es wird ja in der halbzeitbilanz
gezogen könnte auch ihre halbzeitbilanz
negativ ausfallen
oder wird die union unter allen
umständen der gruppo festhalten
zunächst einmal ist glaube ich nicht so
sehr der blick zurück entscheiden wir
werden gemeinsam diese halbzeitbilanz
ziehen vornehmen da wird auch viel auf
der habenseite stehen die koalition hat
ja in den letzten anderthalb jahren
trotz aller anderen diskussionen in der
sache sehr engagiert gearbeitet und dann
geht es aber natürlich darum den blick
nach vorne zu richten zu überlegen wie
man in diesen zeiten die sich auch
verändern die notwendigen impulse setzen
kann
wir sind ständig mit selbstbespiegelung
und beschäftigt insgesamt in den
debatten im land zum teil auch in den
parteien und um uns herum verändert sich
die welt dramatisch außen und
sicherheitspolitisch brauchen wir
dringend eine gemeinsame position der
der regierung und das was sich jeder
türkei mit unserem außenminister eignet
hat habe ich so auch noch nicht erlebt
hochgradig schädlich
wir treten eine wirtschaftspolitisch in
sehr anspruchsvolle zeiten und wie lange
der lange aufschwung neigt sich dem ende
zu das heißt auch hier müssen wir neue
impulse geben
ich glaube es gibt viel zu tun für eine
große koalition
und wir sollten gemeinsam schauen wie
wir wachstumsimpulse geben können damit
dieses land auf gutem kurs bleibt wir
jedenfalls csu sehen uns in dieser kohl
großen koalition als stabilitätsanker
und auch als du wirst als taktgeber
wie bewerten sie denn den ausgang
gestern bei der spd die beiden teams die
jetzt antreten
also ich kann noch nicht erkennen das
ist jetzt die sache wesentlich einfacher
gemacht hat und wir wünschen einfach der
spd der sie dann relativ schnell klar
ist wer künftig wie
spd führt das ist auch für die große
koalition entscheidend dass die parteien
in sich natürlich stabil sind
jetzt legen wir ein kurzes wort weil der
aus minister gerade angesprochen wurde
das läuft ja einiges schief zwischen
ihnen der außenminister hat die
regierungspolitik vertreten ich glaube
es war letzte woche anfang letzter woche
eine andere ministerin die ausgeschert
ist die auf einmal neue positionen ohne
rücksprache auf den tisch gelegt hat und
ich kann also nicht erkennen wo der
außenminister aus aktuelle
regierungspolitik ausgeschert ist oder
eine andere linie vertreten hat da
braucht man noch mal zurück zu herrn
röcke der verfassungsschutz präsident
hat ja gerade der flügel werde immer
extremistischer was heißt denn das für
ihre partei
wenn sie jetzt jemanden haben mit einem
solchen erfolg von dem der
verfassungsschutz sagt auch der flügel
werde immer extremistische der
verfassungsschutz ist leider missbraucht
worden als waffe im politischen kampf
als waffe gegen die afc ich habe das
genauso im bundestag auch die rede dazu
gehalten
das ist ein präsident des
verfassungsschutzes entlassen worden ich
war im innenausschuss hat die ganzen
dinge gesehen wie das passiert ist nun
ein etwas geschmeidiger gewählt worden
den mussten wir über eine entscheidung
des verwaltungsgerichtes in köln hat
glaube ich ein ordentliches gericht
verbieten dem verfassungsschutz uns als
prüfer die als prüfer zu bezeichnen und
journalisten waren doch weiter sie sind
es ja weiter doch doch zu bezeichnen
der durfte der verfassungsschutz die
muster verboten werden durch ein
ordentliches deutsches gericht die afd
wo finde ich als prüfer zu bezeichnen
das ist so weiter also das zeigt doch
wieder wie der verfassungsschutz
missbraucht wird hier in der republik
so sehen wir das fragen sie doch mal den
herrn von der linken der hatte auch die
kommunistische plattform die wird seit
jahr und tag vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet warum ist das kein thema in
dieser runde
warum immer dieses gleiche soße aus
links-grün mainstream bashing auf die
afd
es ist doch so dass zwei drittel der
wähler mittlerweile sagen in umfragen
allensbach man muss angst haben in
diesem land überhaupt noch zu
diskutieren politisch wenn es um
bestimmte themen geht angst haben seine
meinung zu sagen
allensbach frage kommen sie mit dem
verfassungsschutz das ist genau dieses
klima was erzeugt wird und dass die
bürger dass die wähler nicht mehr wollen
und das ergebnis sehen sie am heutigen
abend wahlergebnis in der wahlkabine
erst hat es keiner religion ein
millionenpublikum und können ihre
meinung sagen sie können im bundestag
ihre meinung sagen
vielleicht gehen sie konsequenzen die
man auch von einem sehr rüden ton der in
der republik mittlerweile herrscht dass
menschen sich nicht mehr trauen aber
rüder ton einer partei die jetzt ein
viertel aller wähler hat als nazis oder
extremisten zu gibt es einen rüden ton
die nazis h million menschen umgebracht
da geht es doch nicht das doch die
heuchelei schlechthin sozusagen von
ihrer warte jetzt noch zu sagen wir
würden spalten in jedem jahr so auch sie
sagen heute ihre aus jedem was sie sagen
heute abend kommt spaltung urteil das
fest ein gericht das festgestellt hat
dass die haben ja als verschifft haben
gerade ein kann und sie stellen doch
sicherlich die arien rechtsstaat in
frage sie haben alles gestellt in der
alle daten fragen sie also diese fragen
wie ein juristisches wissen dass ihre
röcke als faschist bezeichnet werden
kann in frage dann sagen sie das hier
doch danach den deutschen gerichten und
das sei ein problem dass hitler nach den
deutschen nachrichten dafür jeder
mittlerweile als alles bezeichnet werden
das hat mir der türke gar nichts zu tun
so könnten sie auch als faschist
bezeichne so irgendwas die gerichte
würden da genauso recht geben wir haben
ja gerade vom verfassungsschutz geredet
aber das war glaube ich die antwort auf
die frage zum verfassungsschutz
aber sie haben doch noch eine
zusatzfrage gestellt ja aber das hat
sich jetzt erschöpft regel über 50
prozent haben in thüringen die ränder
des politischen spektrums gewählt auch
wenn die nicht vergleichbar sind
wirklich nicht was sagt es uns dennoch
über den zustand des parteiensystems
wir erleben ja dass das parteiensystem
wahnsinn im umbruch wahnsinnig im fluss
ist und eine eine konsequenz seit ich
habe vorhin schon gesagt dass parteien
aller alle hause afd
alle demokratischen parteien miteinander
gesprächsfähig und auch regierungsfähig
sein müssen so das sind alles keine
liebesheiraten das ist alles nicht schön
aber es ist eine aufgabe der wir uns
stellen müssen der wir uns als grüne
stellen und verantwortung versuchen zu
machen und lasse ich noch sagen was ich
auch sehr weil diesen wahlergebnissen
wir sehen eine große stadt eine spaltung
zwischen stadt und land und das ist eine
aufgabe für politik die man anpacken
muss also in thüringen ein ergebnis was
ist überhaupt nicht zufrieden stellt wir
haben gerade in hannover wahrscheinlich
die stärkste partei bei der
oberbürgermeisterwahl und dieses
auseinanderklaffen zwischen stadt und
land ich war diese woche sowohl im
bergischen land also ich würde im
übrigen gerne reiten hat ein system
gleiche leistung von von kommunen und
das haben wir in der
wahlberichterstattung auch thematisiert
aber ich würde gerne beim parteien
system bleiben die zeit der
volksparteien in der für uns vertrauten
form scheint ja abzulaufen wir sehen
hier
wir haben sieben parteien am tisch eine
zersplitterung des parteiensystems was
heißt das für die zukunft unseres
unserer demokratie also es gibt diese
konzept von volksparteien und 20
jahrhundert ecken kanten abschleifen
diese frage von beliebigkeit sie wird
nicht mehr funktionieren das heißt mit
einer klaren für uns grüne heißt es eine
klare bündnis partei alle sind
eingeladen mitzumachen die vorangehen
wollen einen echten klimaschutz
vorangehen wollen
für eine weltoffene gesellschaften wo
ihm menschen nicht als gesindel
bezeichnet werden ehemalige gastarbeiter
wie dass ein kollege aus der afd gerade
gemacht hat was ich finde eine verlegung
verleihen eine form von der verlorenen
tochter in der gesellschaft ist die wir
nicht wollen und die vorangehen wollen
in einer gesellschaft für soziale
gerechtigkeit die beispielsweise eine
grundrente eine garantierente schafft ja
nicht erst bei 35 jahren greifen bei 30
jahren ich würde gerne ich würde gerne
wenn sie erlauben die schlussrunde ein
dann läuten und sie alle bitten zu einer
fragestellung zu nehmen drehen sie die
uhr bitte ein jahr weiter welche
regierungskonstellation werden wir haben
unter welchem kanzler unter welcher
kanzlerin
und wie ist es dazu gekommen ich glaube
die große koalition ist im elend fest
umklammert und wird uns noch ein
weiteres jahr begleiten herr baumann ich
sage da überhaupt keine prognose da ist
alles möglich dass die tektonischen
veränderungen bei den wählern die gerade
stattfinden und es kommt darauf an ob
die cdu auf lange sicht sich entscheidet
mit links grün zusammenzugehen mit
willkommenskultur mit clans öko verboten
und klimasteuer waren oder zu einer
bürgerlichen hat sozusagen zu einer
bürgerlichen koalition findet die man
früher mit der cdu verbunden und helmut
kohl rechtsstaat grenzsicherheit und
alle diese dinge das ist die
entscheidende frage in der
ich hoffe dass ich eine andere politik
durchgesetzt hat dann ich hoffe dass es
um solidarität geht um weltoffenheit und
nicht um grenzsicherung und ähnlichem
klimbim von gestern sondern dass es
darum geht wie wir die zukunftsfragen
der gesellschaft das ist bildung das ist
der investitionsstau das sind die
schulen dass wir das angehen und unsere
regierung unter dieser regierung wird
das nicht möglich sein das sieht man ja
jeden tag
es bleibt in diesem zusammenhang nur
eine regierung bestehend aus grünen spd
und linken selbstverständlich erklingt
also wenn wir von der situation im jahr
reden dann eher haben wir eine regierung
ich hoffe dass die eine positive
halbzeit bilanz ziehen kann und dass wir
noch nötige kraft für die zweite
halbzeit hat und neue themen
digitalisierung bildung
es gibt ja einiges was wir tun müssen
noch in diesem land dass sie diese
anpackt ja wir werden alles dafür tun
dass diese regierung erfolgreich
arbeitet wir haben zukunftsthemen vor
der brust wir werden den vorsitz im
europäischen rat übernehmen das ist ganz
entscheidend auch für die zukunft
europas und nicht eine diskussion über
parteien sondern über die zukunft
deutschlands über die zukunft der
jetzigen kanzlerin unter der jetzigen
unter der jetzigen kanzlerin bis 2021
und daran werden wir arbeiten die
minderheitsregierung sondern in der
jetzigen rucola in der jetzt noch mal
diese diskussion führen wir nicht die
für eine andere sollen sie auch alle
führen uns geht es darum auch den
unterschied deutlich zu machen übrigens
sage ich ihnen ich bin nach wie vor
überzeugt dass volksparteien nicht nur
sinn haben sondern auch eine zukunft
haben wir haben das auch in österreich
gesehen mit sebastian kurz mit seinem
wahlergebnis ist zeigt sich jetzt auch
bei den grünen auch der wahre kern dass
man sich sehr zugeneigt würden nicht zu
bürgerlicher politik sondern mit zu
einer politik mit ganz links außen hier
in der blume und frau heute dank ich
sehe diese regierung mit neuer
leidenschaft für die zukunft arbeiten
und mit klaren kurs fürs land wie sc
sowie in den wurster unseren beitrag
leisten
sie haben nach einer prognose gefragt
auch wir denken dass die groko er so
beharren wird und so umklammert ist dass
sie auch in einem jahr noch regieren
wird aber was wir bräuchten ist etwas
ganz anderes nämlich eine politik die
sich nicht um die ränder und die mitte
von den rändern die agenda diktieren
lässt sondern endlich auch was tut für
die entlastung der bürger und die krise
abwendet statt sie nur mit
kurzarbeitergeld oder andere
zu bearbeiten und zu verwalten dafür
stehen wir vielen dank
vielen dank diese runde das war die
berliner runde am abend der letzten wahl
des jahres 2019 vielen dank für ihr
interesse vielen dank hier in die runde
und damit zurück ins wahlstudio und
bettina schausten und matthias fornoff
und zu den neuesten zahlen
ja so ist es vielen dank theo koll
soweit also die berliner runde und
herzlich willkommen hier noch einmal
kurz zurück geben zdf wahlstudio bevor
wir sie wohl verdient ins abendprogramm
entlassen wollen wir hier noch einmal
den letzten stand der dinge beleuchten
und auch ein bisschen ordnen denn dieses
jahr ohne zweifel ein ganz besonderer
wahlabend zunächst jetzt gehört immer
dazu
der letzte stand der hochrechnungen
matthias fornoff weil es so knapp ist
muss man sich das noch mal anschauen wir
haben eine neue hochrechnung und hier
sind die zahlen 20 uhr 10 die cdu
demnach bei 22,1 prozent deutliche
verluste
die linke 30,4 prozent mit zugewinnen
die spd 8,1 prozent verliert die afd
23,5 prozent fast 13 punkte zugelegt die
grünen bei 5,1 prozent leichte verluste
die fdp bei 5,1 prozent zu gewinnen
beide sind noch nicht in stein gemeißelt
im parlament im laufe des abends sind
sie beide etwas zurückgegangen im moment
sehen wir sie über der fünf prozent
hürde
dann schauen wir uns mal an was das für
die sitzverteilung heißt im erfurter
landtag die absolute mehrheit bei 45
sitzen
die cdu hat 21 die linke hätte 28 ist
erstmals stärkste partei die spd sieben
die afg 22 sitze die grünen 5 und die
fdp ebenfalls fünf wenn wie gesagt beide
denn über die fünf prozent hürde kommt
was heißt das alles fürs regieren hier
in erfurt
diese senkrechte linie ist das
entscheidende 45 sitze muss man
erreichen die im moment regierende
koalition von linken spd und grüne
verfehlt das deutlich kommt nur auf 40
ein bündnis aus cdu spd grünen und fdp
wegen der farbkombination aus simbabwe
genannt kommt auf 38 sitze schafft ist
also auch nicht die ungewöhnliche
konstellation linke spd grüne fdp käme
genau auf diese 45 sitze
mindestens braucht zum regieren und die
von der cdu ausgeschlossene variante
linke und cdu
die käme auf 49 sitze und wäre deutlich
drüber
das ganze bei einer erhöhten
wahlbeteiligung bei jetzt 66 prozent
dankeschön matthias fornoff und wir
haben heute bei uns in der wahlsendung
gesehen noch bewegt sich niemand das
allerdings wäre möglich um dann zu einer
tatsächlich belastbaren
regierungsmehrheit zu kommen ja an
diesem tag geht dann jetzt auch der
herbst der wahlen in ostdeutschland zu
ende
drei mal haben wir das gehört zu dem
befund gesehen dass die afg
zweitstärkste kraft geworden ist und es
ist viel diskutiert worden über
befindlichkeiten über die gründe der
ostdeutschen wähler diese partei zu
wählen
das ist auch eingeflossen in die
vorbefragung und analysen der
forschungsgruppe wahlen matthias jung so
ist es bettina denn es gibt ja viele
faktoren die auf das wahlverhalten
einzahlen oder einfluss darauf nehmen
wir haben zum beispiel jetzt mal eine
these in den raum gestellt die
ostdeutschen werden wie bürger zweiter
klasse behandelt stimmen sie dem zu oder
nicht und da sagen in thüringen so
ungefähr fifty fifty
dem stimme nicht zu oder auch nicht zu
wenn man das jetzt mal nach anhängern
der parteien aufgliedert dann sieht man
77 prozent der afg anhänger sagen genau
wir ostdeutschen werden wie bürger
zweiter klasse behandelt und dieses
gefühl der ungerechtigkeit kann offenbar
die auf die afg für sich nutzen
die frage in ostdeutschland wer kümmert
sich denn besser am ehesten um die
sorgen und probleme der ostdeutschen da
haben wir mal vergleicht thüringen und
sachsen am besten kümmert sich die linke
um die probleme der ostdeutschen das
sagen 40 prozent und damit eine ganz
klare mehrheit in sachsen war das anders
da sehen wir cdu linke und afd
gleichauf und das erklärt auch ein
stückweit warum die linke in thüringen
auf ein starkes ergebnis nochmals
draufgesattelt hat während sie in
sachsen oder auch in brandenburg
deutlich verloren hat danke matthias
interessante daten waren das noch einmal
ja jedenfalls haben wir in thüringen
komplizierte verhältnisse das ist so in
die lotus weiter zu beleuchten ich
empfehle ihnen sehr heute.de das ist
jederzeit eine
gute informative adresse und natürlich
wärmstens um 21 uhr 45 das heute-journal
so und jetzt um knapp 20 uhr 15 wie sich
das gehört leiten wir sie gerne weiter
an die algarve
so heißt der film heute ein sommer an
der algarve viel spaß dabei und schoss
aus erfurt